well prime minister welcome to Britain
good to be with you and glad to be in
London I have a strict rule I have to
confess normally I don't fraternize with
any Australians in the run-up to an
ashes series but I have made an
exception for you well it's going to be
a cracker of a series and uh hopefully
we'll go well any prediction
I always think we're going to win even
when we're rubbish I thought we were
going to win you've got to you've got to
back your team but I think uh you know
our our bowling attack is terrific uh if
Dave Warner can hit form as he did with
his his 200 one of the things about Dave
is that every time he gets written off
he comes out and does very well so I'm
very very positive and I'm looking
forward to watching it you want to hear
my prediction I'm sure I know what it'll
be five nil you're going to get five
Nils seriously buzz balls within one
inch of your life yeah well I must I
must say that the style of cricket that
England are paying is quite
transformative it's terrific it's
exciting and I'm a test Cricket fan so
it's great that I think younger people
will come back to test Cricket because I
think it's the form of the game there's
something about going and chilling out
even when not much is happening uh it's
something quite relaxing during those
five day tests well I will say to my
American friends the great thing about
Cricket is it an ashes series five
matches each one lasts five days each
day seven to eight hours and at the end
of it all the score might be zero zero
that's amazing it's like we're
completely nuts well I I think we are
going to get results from the both very
attacking teams
a legendary Australian cricketer Keith
Miller who flew with your Air Force in
World War II
it's once asked about pressure and he
said pressure is having a measurement up
your bleep
you've been prime minister not even a
year yet
how's it going I mean just the reality
when I last saw you you were contesting
the vanilla election
and you've been a career politician but
this moment now this period what's it
been like for you well I'm enjoying it
it's an incredible privilege and an
honor to be the prime minister of a
country that I love dearly and one that
I think is the greatest country on Earth
with respect to the UK but I think can
be even greater in the future and it's
an exciting time for us I'm very proud
of what my government has done and in
the first 12 months what you can do
really is just set the agenda and give
the narrative what's the character of a
government and I think my government to
government that delivers on our
commitments that gets things done that
is making a practical difference to
people's lives that addresses immediate
challenges but also never has our eye
off that medium and long-term changes
that we need to do you're here for our
coronation of King Charles III
how do you feel about that you're a
lifelong Republican
what are you doing here prime minister
well I think you can be a lifelong
Republican which I am and still respect
our institutions and certainly I have a
great deal of respect for King Charles I
am having an audience with him this
afternoon and I'm very much looking me
in the morning the king in the afternoon
I like the way your schedule's going
brother I'm very much out looking
forward to it uh I had a terrific
meeting with him at the palace when I
was here for his mother's funeral that
was a real moment of of reflection that
was an extraordinary time and it's a
great honor to be here representing
Australia all Australians Wish King
Charles well regardless of the different
views that people will have about our
constitutional Arrangements
the queen you were hoped for the
funerals he said and you actually went
to her lying estate at Westminster Hall
what was that experience like for you it
was very moving the the queen uh
Elizabeth was of course the only uh Head
of State uh in my lifetime up to that
point and she was a constant in our
lives a reassuring presence so her
passing was something that was a very
significant event
but she also I think was very loved and
respected by all
to lead
your nation and the Commonwealth for
seven decades is extraordinary we won't
see that certainly you and I won't see
that again and I think people uh the the
cues as we we went running one morning
along the Thames and the cues of people
including Australians who had traveled
to London in order to queue for 36 hours
to pay their respects to the the Her
Majesty lying in State uh was a
remarkable time when you were standing
there with your partner and you were
paying your own personal respects did
you feel emotional in that moment
notwithstanding your your long-held
position about the monarchy well it's a
moment in history I had the great honor
of I met at Queen Elizabeth at the at
the palace during the first G20 that was
held during the global financial crisis
and her leadership and her capacity her
strength was quite remarkable and her
passing was a very significant moment in
the world's history and unlike in
previous monarchs of course she
came to that position at such a young
age and during the era the first era of
Television modern Communications so the
pressure that she was under during those
seven decades of course grew and she
carried herself with such dignity and
Grace during that entire period your
birth was actually delayed because of
the queen well
my mother was well kind of true my
mother was on her way to the hospital in
1963 and the queen was of course
visiting
Australia and my mother insisted on
going through the streets and seeing the
banners and the commemorations for her
visit on the way to give birth to me so
that that was my mum and that was that
is something uh that is an example my
mother voted
yes in the Republic but she had enormous
respect for her majesty the queen
this question of what happens to
Australia whether it becomes a republic
it's obviously it's not going to go away
many people think it's inevitable Hugh
Jackman was recently quoted one of your
great national heroes saying it's
inevitable you voted in the 1999
referendum in favor of Republic and said
it's inevitable everybody accepts that
but that referendum came back 55 against
uh saying yes to a republic
my first question are you going to have
another referendum while you're prime
minister
my uh sole priority that I've put
forward uh for constitutional change is
to recognize Aboriginal Torres Strait
Islander people in our Constitution and
to listen to them through a voice what's
called a voice essentially that they be
consulted on matters that affect them
and that's a referendum that will hold
between October and December that's my
timetable I'm not looking beyond that I
think that Australia should have an
Australian as our head of state I don't
shy away from that I haven't changed my
views but my priority is constitutional
recognition I can't imagine going
forward for example as was suggested has
been suggested by some legitimately that
we should be having another referendum
on the Republic
before that occurs for me the the
absolute priority is once you've done
that recognition right but once you've
done that it would be odd for somebody
who's such a die-hard republican as you
notwithstanding your respect for the key
players in the royal family and the
monarchy which you've shown in this
interview already
standing there'd be very odd wouldn't it
if you were a prime minister and you
didn't want another referendum movie
otherwise what's been the point of
posing it all this time well look I I
think at some stage in the future
that will occur would you like it to
happen but either your tenure what I
don't want to do is to be a prime
minister who presides over just
constitutional debates
and that's right and that's why they are
they are but so is dealing with the
challenge of climate change getting an
economy that works for people making
more things in Australia engaging in our
region uh to restore our relationships
as one of the tasks that that I've had
as prime minister so I've said quite
clearly that that's my priority uh
you'll you'll know because there'll be a
feeling from the bottom up as well a a
demand for
another another vote isn't something
that can be imposed from the top because
it won't be successful when that that
demand is there I'm sure a vote will be
held how close to that feeling do you
think Australia is because the polls
have been all over the place I I don't
see it as being imminent
but if you were to win a second term
potentially you could have a referendum
well I don't see as being imminent
you're being very diplomatic here prime
minister is that because you're here for
a monarchy which many of your supporters
would be like hang on you've come here
to London to watch a king being crowned
the head of an institution that you just
don't agree with yeah but part of part
of the job of being the Australian prime
minister is to represent all Australians
not just to put forward my own views
which are clearly there but it is
important that the Australian prime
minister and the governor general and
all of the governors and we have some
prominent Australians coming along as
well on Saturday Sam Kerr yeah great
footballer she will be the flag bearer
on on Saturday and and I chose her put
her forward I thought that was a really
appropriate thing to do someone who's a
a young Dynamic Australian Sports woman
who hopefully will lead us to World Cup
glory in the Women's World Cup that's uh
that's coming up being hosted in
Australia in a couple of months time so
what are you going to do in Westminster
Abbey when you are urged to say the oath
of Allegiance I did to King Charles I I
do that every term I know are you going
to say it in the Abbey with the world's
cameras watching I I I I will do what's
entirely appropriate as the
representative of Australia which is
Australians made a choice in 1999 and
one of the things that you've got to do
is to accept Democratic outcomes uh we
made that choice and I will uh certainly
uh engage in that spirit so you will say
that as I have as I have done 10 times
yes but just to be clear in the air it's
been confusion over whether you will as
the Prime Minister Australia in the
Abbey on Saturday you will say the oath
as as the Prime Minister of Australia
it's expected that that I will do that
but that doesn't mean of course that
Australians don't have a wide range
friendship views and it's also the case
that as Australian prime minister I'm
accountable to the Australian people I
mean that that too I serve and I have
that great honor do you know the words
to the oath
well I know the oath that that I give in
the uh in uh in Parliament each time I
swear that I will pay true allegiance to
your majesty and to your heirs and
successes according to law so help me
God there's been a lot of of actually I
would say a lot of Kickback here
about this entreaty which has come from
the Archbishop of Canterbury
the the public the British public and a
wider world of course including those in
the Commonwealth should all crowd run
their TV sets and recite this because as
people have pointed out
airs and successes
well that could be if we're unlucky
prince Andrew
or God forbid
Harry and Megan
well people will make their own
decisions uh on on Saturday but I think
it will be a very significant historic
event
the Australian Republican movement the
Australian Republic movement has called
on all Australians to pledge allegiance
to Australians and Australian values on
Coronation Day and not quote obey the
Absurd request of King Charles for us to
pledge fealty to him and his heirs and
successes as a republican from Australia
what's your message to them I pledge
allegiance to the Australian people each
and every day and that's our democratic
system that we have and it's one yeah I
think people will have uh these these
views but I think that they're your
views
absolutely I I pledge my allegiance to
the Australian people they are the
people I'm accountable for but are you
at all worried tomorrow that you're
Republican
people back in Australia the side that
you actually agree with they're going to
see you on Saturday
declaring your oath of allegiance to not
just King Charles but to all his heirs
and successes when actually really what
you want to do is get rid of the
molecule it is a strange conundrum right
no no no
our position that the position of the
Australian Republican movement isn't
about getting rid of the monarchy that's
the decision for the UK the decision of
the arm is an Australian should be the
Australian head of state yeah and that's
one I agree with I think you would do
that but Australia would I would hope
continue to be involved in the
Commonwealth but I'm at The View that an
Australian should be our head of state
there's a new poll out today about the
British uh Public's view of this
overwhelming support for the monarchy
two-thirds said it may seem a strange
system in this day and age but it works
and that's kind of my view about this I
mean I feel uneasy about this over to be
honest I won't be saying it the way they
want me to because I'm not going to
commit to having allegiance to prince
Andrew and Prince Harry
um
but there's an interesting statement
there by the public which is they know
it's a bit anachronistic we know it's
kind of weird to have people
in palaces not paying proper taxes no of
course we do and yet the British public
feels quite strongly the overriding
benefits of a monarchy outweigh the
negatives and that's the right of the
British people to determine uh that's
that's the point I'm making here
I guess as someone who supports an
Australian head of state we should
determine who our head of state is and
the United Kingdom should determine who
their head of state is you don't have a
view about the the actual institution of
the monarchy well that that I I'm not a
monarchist uh you would get rid of it
well we don't have an Australian
royal family that's that's the point but
you have one of our roles as your head
of state exactly but that's the point
because that's a contradiction in itself
that's why I think Australia should have
our own head of state and I'm at The
View uh that I think that should be an
appointed head of state there should be
some uh process whereby our
democratically elected institutions in
the House of Representatives and the
Senate have a say in that there's
various models it's one of the things
that's held back the change in Australia
is the failure to agree on a way forward
but I would I would hope that Australia
would still of course remain a member of
the Commonwealth of an Australia and an
undemocratic monarchy really exist going
forward go for 10 20 30 years we've seen
the rapid removal of most monarchies in
Europe in the last 50 years or so I mean
do you think that a monarchy the idea
the concept has any real future well
that's a matter for the United Kingdom I
myself am a Democrat and believe in
Democratic institutions and that that is
how we should be governed and that is
how we should determine so you don't
believe you don't believe in the idea of
the state no I'm a republican but that
doesn't mean that I don't respect the
institution uh which is there which
plays a role in our system of government
I have to meet with the governor general
regularly the governor general has to
sign off on our pieces of legislation
and I I respect that and I think that
it's important that institutions which
are there that have been determined be
given that respect and I see my role as
the Australian prime minister in doing
that when you see the king later
um how are you going to explain that
you've decided to remove his image or
not have his image on your five dollar
banknotes given it's always
traditionally been whoever the Monarch
is
you've decided as a government you're
not going to do this are you going to
are you going to cough up to this when
you see King Charles I I I'm sure that
uh it won't be raised the Kings
portrait the official one will be on the
back of every coin and of course our
dollar notes uh the truth is that
they've all changed at various times as
well including the five dollar note so
this was I think Much Ado About Nothing
frankly uh well except you've always had
the Queens no it hasn't always been on
the five dollar note that's right that's
actually not true and indeed we we
haven't even have we've had different uh
currencies of course we went decimal in
in 1966 so there's a whole history of
nothing personal there not at all not at
all that decision was made actually by
The Reserve Bank it wasn't even made by
the government an independent body they
consulted the government and we were
were comfortable with the decision that
was made to have an an indigenous
representation artwork on the five
dollar note which of course with the one
dollar note that was abolished that used
to have so the lowest denomination of
note of currency used to have the
indigenous artwork on it
Megan and Harry have dominated
headlines for three years do you have a
view about them do you think they should
be able to keep their Royal titles ah I
I have of all the things that come
across my desk
that I'm concerned about global
inflation uh the increasingly insecure
world the war in Ukraine uh dealing with
the challenge of climate change I've got
to say Harry and Megan have not been
front and center of my thoughts will you
be sinking Harry out in the Abbey for a
little chat uh I spoke to Harry very
briefly at the at his his mother's
funeral uh his grandma his grandmother
sorry and passed on my respects and uh
I I I don't know whether I'll see him or
not but if I did I'd say hello
Australia's other Queen Dame Edna
everage quite sadly died Barry Humphries
incredible amazing Comic character
um
what were your thoughts about Barry
Humphries Jessica Barry Humphries was
the quintessential Australian character
uh Barry Humphries brought Australians
Australian laricanism really to life
and in the characters uh including of
course most famously uh Dave Edna but
Sandy Stone and and of course he can
forget who can forget that great
Australian politician Les Patterson
Australians have a particular sense of
humor I think British humor is different
from American humor I'm I'm a fan of
Monty Python going back and Blackadder
and and shows like that that could only
have come from the UK
Barry Humphries could only have come
from Australia
what Barry Humphries would say is taking
the piss out of ourselves
and he did it so well and for such a
long period of time so it was a big loss
for the Australian Arts community and of
course he was equally as big here in the
United Kingdom and it says something
about our common history that that we
share and that engagement and
interaction I don't know that Barry
Humphries was very big in the United
States or in Asia or in uh in
Continental Europe but in the United
Kingdom he was big and in Australia he
was of course Larger than Life and there
was a great deal of mourning of him his
comedy rather light uh actually Monty
Python Blackadder all those kind of
shows which I love too almost certainly
wouldn't survive the modern curse of
cancel culture because of the
inappropriateness Apparently Barry
Humphries was canceled by the Melbourne
International comedy show they took his
name off it top award for him being
allegedly transphobic what did you feel
about that was but I I didn't know I
wasn't even aware of that I must say
until recent recent times and and I
think people uh
legitimately can put forward their
concerns about someone's comments uh
that were made then but at the same time
um I I think that we've got to be able
to to laugh at ourselves uh I think that
a lot of humor you're quite right that a
lot of humor that used to be on I mean
Faulty Towers I'm not sure how that
would go never never make it I'm not
sure
this whole idea and I think there are
only there were only yeah I think there
were 12 episodes of Faulty Towers and uh
they were fantastic though good fun and
they weren't um
yeah it might be today you look at it
and you go you know well you know uh
maybe you you might do it differently
but a bit like um rewriting some books
um it is what it is at the time and it's
it's the uh it that's the context and
and I think that the idea of cancel
culture is in my view uh a sad
development because you you're often can
get as well uh pylons in social media
and you see it happen so often and
things quite often too taken out of
context I mean I I try not to look at
too much social media but I know that
sometimes people will say something to
me about an answer that in an interview
like this without people having seen the
question or what was said before or or
afterwards and and make it look like
something that it isn't but I think that
we need uh far more should the Melbourne
far more tolerant should the Melbourne
International comedy uh
institution I guess they would call
themselves but should they have canceled
someone like Barry and doesn't do it
actually was that the worst kind of
council gotcha well that now since he
died they've now said we want to pay
homage to him honor it seems to be
stinking hypocrisy yeah well I I know
kind of go into the past because I
wasn't a part of yeah I wasn't going to
be aware that that occurred but I'll say
they said it's good that a tribute is
now being made to Barry Humphries and
there will be a state funeral for Barry
Humphries as well uh co-hosted by uh the
New South Wales and the Victorian
government and the Australian government
my government will be a part of that as
well so you won't be paying tribute no
we'll we'll be paying tribute to him at
a state funeral he's someone who has
given a gave an enormous amount of
pleasure uh to generations of
Australians and I know that a range of
people who are friends of mine I knew
him very well I didn't I met him on one
occasion briefly but I didn't know him
but I know how warmly he was regarded by
people in Australia and in the UK the
issue that got him into hot water
was this issue of gender identity he was
defending JK Rowling the New Zealand
prime minister knew his new prime
minister Chris Hipkins
um was asked to define a woman and he
said well people identify for themselves
he couldn't answer and it was
excruciating to watch to be honest with
you and this has been a sort of hot
potato question for world leaders
some of them seem incapable including
kirst
um
what is a woman prime minister an adult
female how difficult was that to answer
not too hard uh I was asked I was asked
during the campaign actually but I think
that
um you know we we need to I think I
respect
people for whoever they are
and it's up to people to uh you know to
be
respected and and I know that there is
uh some controversy can come at times
like that and I'm not a fan of uh some
of uh the campaign that was recently a
very controversial visit in Australia
that was designed to uh stir up issues
and people who are you know young people
coming to terms with their identity and
who they are I I think that uh they need
to be respected as well what would you
do for example with this issue of
transgender athletes in women's sport
which many world or sporting authorities
are now beginning to move to exclude
them because they say it's simply not
fair well that's an example in that the
sporting organizations are dealing with
that issue
my view is the sporting organization
should deal with that issue does it seem
fair to you the people who were born
biologically male with all the physical
Advantage you better compete against
people born with female biology well in
Australia the sporting codes are able to
deal with that uh and and and they have
and they have effectively and they've
done so in a way in which during the
last campaign there was one of the
candidates uh chosen who
tried to make that front and center that
issue I've got to say as I've gone
around and you know my son played Junior
sport
for both footballers in soccer and
Australian Rules Football and cricket
and everything none of these issues ever
came up and I don't think they're front
and center that's because it wasn't
happening there well I I well you didn't
get biological males competing against
biological women I mean that's that's
the problem with it to me to me I can
support transgender rights to fairness
and equality but right to the point
where they infringe on women's rights I
mean they've got to also have fairness
and equality and that's why sporting
codes uh should be dealing with the
Prime Minister of Australia you must
have a view that's why sporting that's
my view are you ducking it no I'm not no
I'm not I'm saying that what it
shouldn't be done is I've done
to try to politicize an issue that
should be made on its merits based upon
the proper assessment of whether it's
fair or not but done in a way as well
that doesn't seek to essentially Target
a very vulnerable group and that's my
concern I don't think they should be
demonizing anything and that's my
concern as well I get that but I think
there's also there are serious issues
which have to be addressed of course
they are but it should be done without
the targeting of a vulnerable group of
people and that's my view that people
should be respected the sporting codes
are dealing with it and what occurred
when this debate happened in Australia
is the sporting codes said themselves
we're dealing with this we don't need
this to be politicized and we don't need
politicians buying into it
you're going to see Rishi sunak the
British prime minister while you're here
um are you going to mention that you've
just been uh in a poll named the third
most popular Global leader while he
languishes at number 10 and that you
also made time magazines 100 most
influential people and uh in fact the
Prime Minister of Australia and in fact
the prime minister of Canada Justin
Trudeau said that you were effectively a
progressive champion
around the world I mean it's been a good
good couple of months for your prime
minister well well uh prime minister
Trudeau was very generous in his
comments I wasn't aware that I had been
named or that he was writing the
citation until it was uh pointed out to
me by the media I did send him a a
little message saying thank you for his
generous comments and I am looking
forward to seeing him again on the
weekend he of course will be here at the
coronation as the leader of another
Commonwealth country as for the first
that's the first I've heard of it but I
I won't be writing that with Rishi
sooner uh this is my third meeting uh
with him and we'll be talking about the
free trade agreement that can make an
enormous difference for Australia and
for the UK about how we can have mutual
benefit from increased economic
engagement and of course we'll also be
talking about our orcus Arrangements uh
further strengthening the cooperation
when it comes to our defense
one of your predecessors Paul Keating
wasn't exactly complementary about the
orcas Arrangement he described your 368
billion dollar deal for the nuclear
submarines as the worst deal in history
that you could have had 40 to 50
conventional Subs instead he also
attacked you for working with the UK to
offered a great problem of brexit after
that full Johnson Morris destroyed their
place in Europe they're going to put
together Global Britain so we're looking
around for suckers
are you a sucker prime minister
the orcas arrangement to me uh should
surprise no one
Australia if you look at our our history
we have
65 000 of proud history the oldest
continuous culture on Earth is
Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander
peoples but then we have
the relationship with Britain
and that's a relationship that goes back
to 1788 to the First Fleet and ever
since then we have stood side by side as
great democratic nations our Parliament
takes the Westminster system as the
basis of our our democracy and we have
common interests of course since the
second world war in particular under
Labor's prime minister John Curtin we
turn to the United States ever since
then the United States has been our most
critical Alliance partner so getting
greater cooperation between Australia
the United Kingdom and the United States
not just in Australia being able to
build our own
nuclear-powered submarines
is to my mind a very sensible thing to
do in today's uncertain world and I I
know former prime minister Keating made
some colorful comments I have every
respect for Paul but on this I just
disagree with him was brexit a good idea
that was a matter for the United Kingdom
so was that a good idea well as the
Australian prime minister I don't see it
as my place
to put forward matters which are
strictly a matter for the people in the
government of the United Kingdom one of
the big reasons for orchestra course is
the ongoing threat of China potentially
invading Taiwan
Paul Keating said this I dare the prime
minister to explicitly suggest or leave
open the question that Australia might
go to war over Taiwan at the urgings of
the United States or anyone else so
I dare you to answer that question prime
minister well I want a region that is
peaceful that is secure that is stable
and that is prosperous and that's what
we're working towards but one of the
ways that we're also engaging in the
region is by lifting up our national
security we don't apologize for that we
have the orcas Arrangements we've just
had our defense strategic review as well
to look at what are the capabilities
that Australia needs and where do we
need them but do you think China May
Taiwan as many do well
I don't think it is
constructive to speculate on matters uh
like that we support the status quo when
it comes to Taiwan would you would you
support Taiwan if they were invaded we
are
Taiwan is not is not assisted by people
speculating on hypotheticals we support
well President Biden has we he's already
said that America would support them we
support the status quo being maintained
we support stability in the region and
we're investing in our capability but
we're investing in something else as
well we're investing in our
relationships whether it's orcas whether
it's asean whether it's our Pacific
friends through the Pacific
relationships that we have rebuilding
them but also we're engaging in the
region my government hasn't engaged in
uh rhetoric that is inflammatory what
we've said with regard to China is that
we will we will cooperate where we can
we'll disagree where we must and will
engage in our national interest but you
wouldn't just that would you so I
wouldn't sit back if Taiwan was invaded
you wouldn't think back as Australia's
prime minister well I don't I don't see
it as constructive uh to uh to speculate
on on hypotheticals what's important and
and the role of peace and security and
stability in the region is Advanced by
having a very clear position which is
support for the status quo of no
unilateral action uh by uh either side
in in those issues and our position on
China has been to engage constructively
but to continue to put forward that the
impediments to trade should be removed
to say very directly to president XI
that Australians such as Cheng Lee need
to be given proper Justice and that
they're not receiving that at the moment
and to raise those issues to raise human
rights issues so we don't shy away from
that but we do so in a way that's
constructive and respectful and that's
how
you advance uh diplomacy that's how you
advance positive outcomes okay President
Biden said he's running again for for
office in 2024 he would be 82.
and he'd be 86 at the end of the second
term is he too old
that's a matter for the United States
but I don't believe that do you want to
be prime minister 86 anyway we'll see
how I go we'll see how I go that will
have said a shiver down your opponent's
bones but can I say this about President
Biden I think he is doing an
extraordinary job uh I regard him as a
friend of mine I regard him as an
important uh leader of our most
important Ally I'll be welcoming
President Biden to Australia this month
for the quad leaders meeting and he
through his actions not just in
international relations where he is
strengthening the United States as
engagement in the Pacific and Indian
Ocean that's something that we welcome
you don't think he's too old when you're
dealings with him you don't get a
feeling not at all not at all he's
totally on top of his brief he's someone
who's very conscious about uh Regional
Affairs in the indo-pacific region he's
someone who's engaged with our friends
with uh in Asiana I notice today he has
the leader of the Philippines Marcus
there hosting him in the white house
he's also got to engage with potentially
Donald Trump if Trump wins a republican
nomination president Trump is actually
in Britain at the moment are you going
to hook up with him are you going to no
no I I engage with uh with President
Biden I look forward to meeting him
would you be happy to engage with Trump
if he was to win the White House
our relationship with the United States
is a relationship between countries and
between peoples based upon our common
democratic values you'd have no problem
dealing with Donald Trump well well it's
not up to me to determine you wouldn't
have any trouble dealing with it
I'll deal with whoever the president or
or the Prime Minister even if he's been
even if he's facing or the leader he's
been indicted on criminal charges okay
well it's a matter for you comfortable
with that that's a matter for the people
of the United States and I have no
intention
of interfering in their internal
political processes I expressed uh my
concern would an Australian prime
minister do you think be able to
Australian politician be able to run to
be prime minister if they were indicted
on
committing crimes uh well they would I
think speculating on that I in terms of
either a labor or a liberal candidate
would I think have
have issues if that occurred but look I
said uh very clearly I expressed my
concern about the events that occurred
in the capital on January 6 I don't shy
from that I think democracy is a
precious
commodity
a whole lot of the world it's under
threat
and that's why we need to support our
democracy including supporting our
Democratic institutions Russell Crowe
has part owned the South Sydney
rabbitohs the rugby league club and
you're a big fan of them he's known you
a long time a former board member right
so he said this about it with all the
opaque we've had to deal with
the last 10 or 15 years we've got a guy
you who is at least going to tell us the
truth now he might not make the
decisions that you might that you want
individually every time but over time
what Anthony would do is improve the
lives of the people in this country and
he also said you never asked him for
anything and like everybody else
um so he that's a that's a pretty good
review coming from Russell Crowe I
shouldn't think he suffers fools gladly
he thinks you're an honest person you
may make mistakes you might get things
wrong but essentially you're an honest
person and and I am and one of the
things that I've done is prime minister
is to say things the the way that I see
them so we've got a budget coming up
next week now we'll do
a number of measures to assist people
with the cost of living but we can't do
everything
on day one I haven't been in office for
a year yet and it follows almost a
decade of I think a government that was
characterized by inaction and delay and
denial that we're left with a trillion
dollars of debt so we've explained that
but we have fulfilled the commitments
that we made in the lead up to the
election to the best of our capacity but
of course all all governments and all
individuals including myself will make
mistakes from time to time are you
unafraid to admit when you're wrong I'll
give an example the small boats policy
which is a big issue here big issue in
Australia you know what you do with
people who wash up on your Shores you
were very opposed to it and you changed
your mind is that is that political
expediency the reality no it will it's
looking at the X the way that uh they
are
and and and being up front about it you
said this in 2015. I couldn't ask
someone else to do something I couldn't
see myself doing if people were in a
boat including families and children I
myself couldn't turn mud around
but now you can what changed uh the
facts
um I didn't think that uh well you still
get people at the families and kids
turning up in boats I mean they are
still happening and and they have been
turned around are you comfortable at the
time yes because if you look at uh what
happened in practice with boat turnbacks
uh the view of what was occurring was
that the advice uh to us when we're in
government that if you tried to do that
then they'd Scuttle the boats and and it
would result in in tragedies
um so uh the the fact is though that the
boat turnbacks policy was a part of
something that did make a difference I
support an orderly migration program I
have said that you can be strong on
borders without being weak on Humanity
so one of the things that my government
has done because
we have ensured that the boats contrary
to what the conservative said before the
election campaign I must say some of the
media as well said oh well if if Labor's
elected the boats will start and it'll
all start back that hasn't happened we
have kept in place strong border
security measures but we also have an
increasingly Humane policy so for
example that the people who had arrived
and were in limbo for more than 10 years
on temporary protection businesses who
no government was going to send back to
Iran or to Afghanistan we have said that
they should be entitled to permanent
security to become permanent residents
as well so we've abolished those
temporary protections when you're tough
on Border your anti-cancel culture
you know what a woman is
are you sure you're a progressive left
not a secret story in Disguise I I I'm
an absolutely uh
who actually realizes the woke left is
pretty nutty I'm a safe way Madness lies
I'm a Social Democrat who believes in
markets but believes that the state the
power of the state can make a positive
difference to people's lives that
believes that the philosophy I took to
the election was two two-part
now on held back and no one left behind
now on held back what does that mean
that people aspiring to a better life
for themselves and for their families is
a legitimate thing we need economic
growth we need to that's why I want to
make more things in Australia that's why
I want to lift Wages that's why I want
industry policy to kick in that's why I
want to challenge climate change and to
tackle it because we've seen
because he's obviously been at the
Forefront of that for many years oh he's
had a very strong position in it he's
been proven right Charles about oh yeah
environment and climate change he
certainly has been and one of the things
about King Charles over a long period of
time is that the stance that he has made
on climate change on the urban
environment as well on indigenous issues
are ones that I think bring him great
credit now I won't talk about what I
will talk to him about that because that
the protocol is that that remains a
private discussion and we'll have a
discussion this afternoon but I
certainly think that he stance on those
issues has been very significant but to
go back to because I don't want to miss
the second Point second point about what
a labor prime minister does is we don't
leave people behind so we're looking at
that in terms of the budget but we're
doing that as well with cheaper child
care to allow greater women's Workforce
participation we're dealing with that as
well through things like
I marched in the Mardi Gras to show my
support for inclusiveness and I'll
continue to do that we are having a
referendum to give indigenous people
recognition in our nation's Constitution
I think you can do both things and
that's something that my government is
is focused on achieving we're only one
year in
to to our our first term been quite yeah
isn't it it's been a very busy year
obviously I want to end just just with
this I want to show you a picture
because I found this picture and if I
found it very poignant and I'm sure you
will too you probably remember the
picture this is a picture on a boat and
this is 1962.
and there are two people in that picture
this is the TSS Fair Sky it was a sipmar
lion boat
tell me who's in that picture well it's
my mum sitting there on the uh as I said
Marianne on the the far right she's next
to her brother uh uh George uh and uh
standing up in in white is uh a dashing
fellow who happens to be my father uh
Carlo who was a person on the ship that
my mother traveled to on that long
journey to England to England here where
she lived in London for a while and she
felt pregnant uh she did she had a
relationship with Carlo and uh during I
think not just on the ship but clearly
from piecing it together so you were
conceived in England when he
quite likely that's right so you're
actually you're one of us and when he
visits you're English right I'm still
not going for you in the ashes so don't
try that don't try that on you except
you could have been conceived that's not
going to happen I think I think the
chances are I was yeah I think I was
here uh when the ship used to birth at
Southampton and my mum
travel met him had a relationship with
him fell pregnant
he was in she when she told him he was
engaged to uh someone he's uh the person
who became his wife back in Italy and so
she went back to Australia had me made
the courageous decision in 1963 to be a
single mother and to to raise me she was
very Catholic so it was a difficult
thing for the family and at that time
she was urged to have you adopted she
she was and that was what was very
common uh at that your life could have
been so different it would have been
very different and at the time it was to
be that I had been I would be adopted
out and that the story would be told in
the local community in in the family
that she had got news of my father's
death and that had caused her to the
trauma to to lose her child but she
couldn't do that I was there was a
moment where a nun at the hospital knew
that she was the sort of person who
didn't she just really didn't want that
to happen she was under a bit of
pressure so she brought me into my mum
and my mum was never going to let me go
what a moment it I mean I sliding doors
oh absolutely but incomparable enormous
consequence oh and she then adopted his
name Albanese but continued to to
pretend that he had died in an accident
that's right and I was talking to you
yeah I was told that until I was old
enough when she felt I could understand
you were 14 that's 14 15. uh you know
and how did you feel when you found out
he's potentially still alive oh I at the
time I mean I was a pretty tough young
kid we had a we had a difficult upbring
I mean my mum I had rheumatoid arthritis
and was crippled up was an envelope
pensioner we lived in a council house
where she had lived her whole life my
grandparents had died by then so it was
just me and Mum we didn't have anything
economically but I had her unconditional
love and that was enough for me and so I
said I'm not interested
uh you know that's you're enough for me
which is what she needed to hear so
while she was alive I didn't search for
him but she died in 2000 and uh two my
son had come along uh in 2000 and there
was a moment where I was at her
gravesite and my little boy was very
little said you know where's your daddy
and I sort of realized that yeah I
needed to and he had a right to ex here
understand
uh what had happened and so I I had I
guess once she passed away I could then
search for
him without uh bringing any
uh sense that she wasn't all I needed
and so I found him uh in 2000. it's an
amazing story because this is nearly 40
years later yeah 46 years later
incredible I was 46 when uh when we met
right and by pure chance
a friend of yours is now running the
ship company that had been renamed
several times it was now three Carnival
Cruises you knew this woman and she
helped the search and they find your
dad's old employment private details in
some dusty rickety area in Genoa where
the original ship stuff had all been
sent yeah and from that you were able
by now you're you're a minister right
under their trials a minister in the
government
and you're able to track down your
darling you're in a meeting or you're in
your office I think and it's a Thursday
and you get a call from this friend of
yours he's running the the ship company
and she just says we found it it was it
was a remarkable moment and I was
chairing a a Ministry or council meeting
of all the state and territory ministers
so an important meeting that night
and I told my stuff to go on without me
and I just took I took my breath away it
was an extraordinary moment emotional
friend oh it was incredibly emotional
did you shut a tear and then oh
absolutely it was it was uh I didn't
realize
just how significant it was because I
think it is everyone everyone's
different
and relationships are complex as my life
story shows but for me that sense of
identity and belonging
was important you know I had this name
Al benazi and I had said where's your
when asked and I represent a big Italian
constituency as well in Sydney so when I
was asked I would say Naples because
that's where the ship sailed from but in
the end it was Puglia the other side of
of Italy six weeks later
you you're there yeah and the door opens
and then walks your dad this is 46 years
later yeah I we had a we wrote to him uh
and uh wrote a careful letter just
saying that my my mother Mary Ellery was
known to him and that I would be
visiting Italy I was visiting the
European transport minister at the time
uh tayani was based in was an Italian so
I had a meeting with him scheduled so I
I wrote and said I'll be here you know
on this
Day on on this weekend and so I met with
they had an intermediary they were
wondering what was going on here I guess
had an intermediary I told her the story
and she I said I don't want anything out
there anything out of him uh I would
like to meet him I think he's my father
and so I didn't know what to expect and
then the the very next morning I had a
very short window of opportunity because
I had a full schedule I was on my way to
London as well to speak at the
international Maritime organization here
the big conference and uh and he walked
I didn't know what to expect and he just
embraced me and what a moment that was
quite extraordinary how did you feel
hugging your dad that you thought was
dead until you were 14. it was an
incredible moment and and not just him
but uh my half brother and half-sister
came with him and so I I went from
having a a very small family to having a
much larger one and it just gave me that
sense of completeness and and I was I
was very lucky because he passed away in
January of 2014 so we were able to meet
on a few occasions I traveled to Italy I
brought back it was a short meeting so I
brought back my son to meet his
grandfather in the following Easter so
in Easter of
2010 and would any of this happen if
your boy hadn't said what he'd said at
your mum's gravesite quite possibly not
or if uh I someone at Carnival Cruises
happened to be someone I didn't have
done a little and if she hadn't have
known a historian who lives in
Wollongong who who knew where to look
and had found this box of papers
essentially employment files in a port
incredible were you able to be there
when your father died or not I went to
uh I went to visit him in 2013 in
December we lost the election in 2013
but then I'd become Deputy Prime
Minister before we we lost that that
election lost government he wasn't well
so I I went to see him uh I knew that he
was he was dying he was at home in his
family flat there in poulia and when you
were saying goodbye
to each other and that the last thing
that he said to me was that he was glad
that he'd found me
amazing
it was uh quite quite a journey from uh
that beginning to be Australian prime
minister so it's a great deal about our
country it's ahead of us think what
would they have made of you becoming
prime minister your parents
um well my my mum would have uh
shed a tear perhaps each and every day I
remember my first speech she she was
there up in the uh the gallery and I
couldn't look up because if I had of I
would have been hopeless as well she was
incredibly proud and I see what I do
as you know her treatment without her
and that unconditional love of a parent
for their their child which which she
gave me you know she did it really tough
she had she really wasn't very well when
she died she was only 65 years old and
she was spent really at the at the end
of what is she a native Journey today
you'll go and see the king
oh she would have happened you know she
would have been having skipped the
journey to hospital diverted with you
Insider uh to see the queen I mean what
an amazing
Journey that has been oh look she would
she would have been uh wrapped by all of
it and uh she would have been very proud
and I I I still think that you know
she's she's looking down on me and uh
she's still with me uh each and every
day because the values that I have
uh the values uh that she gave me and I
say I was raised with three great faces
to go back to Russell Crowe being one of
them the Catholic Church uh South Sydney
football club and the Australian labor
party and they're the values that I have
and that that I hold very dear prime
minister it's been a real pleasure what
an extraordinary story uh your story is
and thank you for sharing it with me
yeah thanks very much good luck with my
king when are you going to see him
indeed I'll I'll say g'day to him please
do great to see you good on you thank
you